[Applause]
here with the incredibly talented
wonderful adam lambert
thank you adam so much thank you you
know the fact that
queen
one of the greatest bands to ever exist
on the planet
came
to you and said you know will you please
step into freddie mercury's shoes will
you please
bring our band
back to life with us and go on tour now
for many years
what is it like to live in a freddie
mercury world
i mean it helps that i i have a lot of
shoes of my own so i i i bring my own
shoes to the party in in figuratively
and literally
um you know i try really hard not to
like mimic him
um because out of respect out of respect
for the fans out of respect for the band
um i remember when i first started i was
very
nervous i was so intimidated the idea of
of taking on the front man position in
queen
was
it was like sacred ground you know what
i mean yeah i was just like oh i don't
know i don't know if the fans are gonna
like be into this or not but i had to
like you know
tough it out and seem confident as best
of my acting ability could make me and
yeah the first couple gigs were
terrifying i was like
i'm so glad that they picked you that
they felt you were capable of
you know taking on such a legend and you
guys have been doing it for years
together and i know you're going to be
performing in vegas
um later this month will you tell us
about that
yeah i mean one of the things that i
love is that yeah i'm so fortunate to be
working with queen all the time and then
i get to have my solo career running
parallel which is like a dream come true
i'm very lucky and
um that's what i'm doing in vegas i'm
doing solo shows at the venetian um
these are songs of my own that i've
written um songs i've put out um there's
some good covers in there and
being that it's the last two weekends of
october
which
hosts my favorite holiday of all time
i'm gonna you know i'm gonna give you a
little spooky dark sided you know kind
of
journey so
anybody that's coming i'm really excited
i'm i'm putting together like you know
video content and my set list and i'm
getting really pumped and also i i
didn't mention just real quick if you
can't come to vegas for the show we are
live streaming the show on the 29th so
check it out all the information's out
there if you can't make it check out the
live stream um before we go actually
ruby um you had a birthday recently i
did last week okay and you have a final
question for adam i do i do adam so no
one officially saying happy birthday to
me and i ruby i know can you believe
that
and i was wondering if you could sing
happy birthday to me
absolutely
absolutely
okay
happy birthday to
you
happy birthday
to you
happy birthday
dear ruby
[Music]
happy birthday
to
you
oh my gosh
um
i have chills everywhere um
oh by the way uh ruby we have a little
birthday surprise for you actually um
you're gonna get a special invite to
adam's livestream concert
um which many people can go and enjoy
actually and if you go to our website at
the drewbramershow.com we'll have all
the details for you on there adam
lambert thank you so much for coming
here today
um
and it's just wonderful and i will be
tuning in
as well as the many other things i
mentioned on your cv i will be watching
your beauty tutorials as well thanks all
right well tune in to the premiere of
clash of the cover bands october 13th at
9 30 p.m on e the best channel ever plus
grab your tickets to see adam perform in
person or on his live stream in las
vegas later this month and be sure to
check out his non-profit as well the
feel something foundation which is ever
so important and will also be featured
on our website for any information so
thank you adam so much
drew thank you so much it's so nice
talking to you it's so wonderful talking
to you too
[Music]
you